y la articulación de la rodilla está
compuesta por el extremo inferior del
fémur que actúa de bisagra en el extremo
superior de la tibia y la rótula que se
desliza por el espacio que se forma
entre los cóndilos femoral es
el reemplazo total de rodilla es un
procedimiento a través del cual la
rodilla que presenta dolor o funciona
mal se reemplaza por componentes
artificiales si el médico le recomienda
un reemplazo total de rodilla
probablemente se deba a que su rodilla
está severamente dañada por la artritis
o lesionada
antes del procedimiento se le
administrarán líquidos antibióticos y
medicamentos por vía endovenosa para
ayudarle a relajarse es posible que se
le coloque un catéter en la vejiga para
drenar la orina la mayoría de los
reemplazos de rodilla se realizan con
anestesia general en cuyo caso se le
insertará un tubo respiratorio en la
garganta para ayudarlo a respirar
durante la operación o bien puede
recibir anestesia raquídea o peridural
en cuyo caso permanecerá despierto
durante el tiempo que lleve el
procedimiento pero sus piernas estarán
anestesiadas debido a que la pérdida de
sangre y de líquido muchas veces puede
ser significativa se tendrán a mano
bolsas de sangre en caso de que necesite
una transfusión la mayoría de los
reemplazos de rodilla llevan
aproximadamente dos horas
el cirujano realizará una incisión a lo
largo del borde delantero de la rodilla
luego de separar los músculos y
ligamentos que rodean la rodilla el
cirujano realizará una incisión en la
cápsula articular de la rodilla para
penetrar en el interior de la
articulación utilizando instrumentos
especiales el cirujano retirará el hueso
y el cartílago dañado de los extremos
del fémur y de la tibia y en la mayoría
de los casos extirpar a la cara inferior
de la rótula
cirujano preparará entonces el hueso
restante para que reciba la nueva
prótesis de rodilla por lo general la
prótesis consiste en un componente
femoral tibial y rotular
una vez que los extremos de los huesos
estén listos
el cirujano pegará con cemento la nueva
prótesis en la posición que corresponda
antes de suturar la incisión el médico
le tomará una radiografía para
asegurarse de que la rodilla se haya
colocado en la posición correcta es
cirujano cerrará la incisión con puntos
o grapas y colocará temporalmente un
drenaje para retirar el exceso de
líquidos
inmediatamente después de la operación
se le colocará una férula que le ayudará
a mantener la rodilla en la posición
adecuada luego se lo trasladará al área
de recuperación para monitorearlo de ser
necesario es posible que reciba una
transfusión de sangre en este momento
una vez que se encuentra estable y haya
despertado de la anestesia se lo
trasladará a una habitación del hospital
donde continuará recibiendo antibióticos
por vía endovenosa durante un breve
periodo y se le administrará medicación
para el dolor en la medida en que lo
necesite para evitar que se formen
coágulos de sangre en la pierna se
administrará un anticoagulante se le
pedirá que use medias de compresión
neumática y se le aconsejará que
comience a caminar lo antes posible
luego del procedimiento una enfermera o
un fisioterapeuta le ayudará a
levantarse de la cama y comenzar a usar
su rodilla nueva la mayoría de los
pacientes son dados de alta del hospital
una vez que son capaces de caminar con
ayuda de muletas o un andador